[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a este nuevo episodio
de reporteros el documental ya su blanco
un gusto acompañarlos hoy por herminio
fernández la iglesia católica- impone
restricciones drásticas a quienes le
sirven a diferencia de los monjes los
sacerdotes no hacen voto de castidad
sino que están obligados al celibato y
por lo tanto a la abstinencia total sin
embargo muchos sacerdotes tienen una
vida sexual activa y están en relaciones
amorosas heterosexuales y homosexuales
en el siguiente reporteros el documental
algunos sacerdotes franceses y sus
parejas acordaron hablar sobre su doble
vida veamos
i
[Música]
marc es sacerdote diocesano en la región
parisina
[Música]
este domingo como todos los otros desde
hace 17 años celebrará la misa
antes de salir tiene tiempo para estar
con inglés una parroquiana de la que se
enamoró hace tres años
divorciada madre de cinco hijos y
siempre ha sido muy activa en la vida
religiosa
fue durante el bautizo de su última hija
cuando se conocieron
algunas de las personas que veían la
parroquia ni siquiera se atrevían a
tocarlo
era como ser sagrado
antes de ser sacerdote nació siendo un
hombre
bueno salió el vientre de su madre era
marzo
era mar antes de ser sacerdote
durante mucho tiempo sufrí por haber
sido puesto en una categoría distinta
nuestra relación era bastante simple
el hijo de ingrid lancelot empezó a ver
a marc de vez en cuando y luego con cada
vez más frecuencia en la casa familiar
el cura vive con ellos desde hace dos
años
[Música]
yo tenía la imagen de cómo debía ser un
sacerdote con el voto de castidad y todo
eso
eso no era romper la ley pero de todas
maneras era inusual había algo raro de
hecho al principio lo tomé bastante mal
muy mal
pero ahora realmente lo considero como
un padre
educado en una familia muy creyente marc
fue scout y luego monaguillo
en la universidad tuvo novias entró al
seminario a los 22 años las mujeres se
convirtieron entonces en un peligro
[Música]
atención vigilancia distancia en
prudencia
esos eran los términos que se utilizaban
y luego me di cuenta de que los jóvenes
que no podían asumir plenamente sus
orientaciones sexuales homosexuales
acababan por refugiarse de cierta manera
en la iglesia lo veía en el seminario y
empezó a llamarme la atención
pero yo seguía seguro la traten de lo
que adhiere a lo que era entregarme por
completo plena y totalmente
así que deje eso de lado y me concentro
en mi vocación
ordenado como sacerdote en sant dennis
sería feliz los primeros dos años
pero seguirían 15 años de hiperactividad
para mitigar las desilusiones y la
sensación de estar atrapado
desafortunadamente hoy en día la iglesia
católica tiene normas que los sacerdotes
deben aceptar creo que en realidad de
manera inconsistente desde hace siglos
la iglesia actúa como una institución de
control hay que mantener al rebaño
controlado yo quería ser un hombre
responsable pleno entero con todo lo que
compone la vida de alguien responsable
es decir también con su capacidad de
amar y ser amado y no ser un instrumento
a los 41 años descubre el amor libre
aunque prohibido
no tuve la impresión de estar rompiendo
ninguna regla surfers lo único fue
cuando nos besamos por primera vez yo lo
decía y él estaba vestido de negro
totalmente porque en esa época se vestía
todo en negro con el alza cuello como un
clérigo me sentí culpable pero no porque
fuera sacerdote
sino por poner en riesgo la buena
amistad que teníamos y pensé que estaba
arruinando algo no tenía nada que ver en
que fuera sacerdote
la vida con un sacerdote en la casa
ahora irá a celebrar la misa por eso me
parece una lástima que no les permitan
vivir eso teniendo una familia porque la
prueba es que lo haces y eso no afecta a
la vida familiar
ni la vida eclesiástica
después de dos años de romance
clandestino la pareja quiso vivir su
amor abiertamente en junio de 2020 marc
se confesó con su superior el obispo lo
trasladó a otra parroquia para alejarlo
de ingrid le aconsejó un tratamiento
psicológico y mantener la castidad
durante un año
si la sexualidad sigue siendo un tabú y
se pervive causará más posibilidades de
derivas lo hemos visto en algunos casos
de la iglesia últimamente no me refiero
solamente a los abusos sexuales a
menores sino también a los abusos
sexuales a mayores sin su consentimiento
algunos dirán que eso existe toda la
sociedad sí pero entre más prohibiciones
y tabúes haya menos será posible vivir
la sexualidad de manera sana
y hay más riesgo que ocurran este tipo
de desviaciones
según marc estas violaciones sexuales
son encubiertas por el silencio cómplice
de la iglesia católica
la cultura del secreto la iglesia es
permanente
proteger actos perjudiciales que ponen
todo en el mismo saco
yo por ejemplo en este momento estoy
obligado a mantener un secreto a estar
en la clandestinidad para poder seguir
el comunista de cierta manera me ponen
en la misma categoría que el sacerdote
que ha abusado de menores todo está
mezclado
hola qué tal
en esta mañana de mayo de 2021 tres
primeras comuniones esperan al padre
marca
lo difícil es no poder compartirlo con
mi entorno no poder decirle a los otros
parroquianos lo que estoy viviendo
porque no estoy viviendo algo contrario
al evangelio ni a la simple humanidad lo
difícil es no poder decir la verdad
y ahora cómo se siente
ahora muy bien
es el encuentro con el señor es algo muy
hermoso
[Música]
lo que vivirán hoy es sólo un paso más
se acercarán entrar en comunión ese
término comunión significa estar unido
con buscamos estar unidos unos con otros
en este mismo amor
[Música]
santifique estas ofrendas extendiendo
sobre ellas tu espíritu que se
conviertan para nosotros en el cuerpo y
la sangre de jesucristo nuestro señor
dentro de 24 horas marks se reunirá con
su obispo para resolver su situación
la solución de la clandestinidad
prácticamente se propuso como solución
para la iglesia y para las autoridades
es más sencillo se puede seguir igual
sin revelar nada mi decisión nuestra
decisión con ingrid siempre fue decir la
verdad también es algo que queremos
hacer en la iglesia al preguntar que
está mal hay algo que ocultar
a diferencia de los monjes los
sacerdotes no toman votos de castidad
solo están obligados al celibato por el
catolicismo o la sexualidad solo puede
ser practicada por una pareja casada el
celibato supone entonces una continencia
absoluta sin embargo muchos sacerdotes
son activos sexualmente y tienen una
vida amorosa dobles vidas secretas
prohibidas conocidas por los sociólogos
de las religiones
como la sexualidad es un tabú es difícil
investigar sobre ella algunos dicen que
alrededor del 50% de los sacerdotes la
practican y el otro 50% no
en todo caso es evidente que existe la
práctica además porque la presión del
ideal sacerdotal es mucho mayor cuando
hay pocos sacerdotes
y actualmente hay un poco más de 8000
sacerdotes en el servicio de la diócesis
las cifras no han dejado de disminuir en
el curso de las últimas décadas a
finales del mes de junio más o menos 120
hombres ingresaron al sacerdocio bien
sea en el marco diocesano o en el marco
de una comunidad religiosa pero frente a
esos 120 que entran fallecen entre 300 y
creo que para muchos la dificultad de
vivir bajo la abstinencia sexual se
concluye progresivamente por una especie
de acuerdo consigo mismo con la norma
tienen una pareja o una aventura de una
noche cada tanto y mientras eso no se
sepa no importa de todas maneras los
obispos necesitan sacerdotes así que no
lo penaliza la imagen del sacerdote con
una sexualidad hiperactiva e incluso
desviada está muy establecida afuera de
la iglesia católica pero por el
contrario adentro a los practicantes les
cuesta mucho trabajo imaginarse que los
sacerdotes puedan tener una vida sexual
desde finales de los años 60 la
revolución sexual ha modificado las
relaciones humanas se reconoció la
sexualidad no reproductiva se reafirmó
la igualdad de los sexos se legalizaron
la contracepción y el aborto sin embargo
poco o casi nada ha cambiado en la
iglesia católica el seminario son
suplirse y si le molino fundado en 1642
es uno de los principales centros de
formación de sacerdotes en francia
actualmente alberga a 36 candidatos al
sacerdocio provenientes de diócesis
francesas y extranjeras
escuchen con atención lo que dice quier
card
más vale un hombre aquí en el
cristianismo escandalice
gracias a ponga relación directa y
profunda consigo mismo que una
especulación que pueda comprender
[Música]
acompañados por sacerdotes y un superior
los seminaristas llevan a cabo aquí su
formación durante seis años dos años de
filosofía seguidos de dos de teología
cada semana reciben quince horas de
clase y tienen veinte horas de trabajo
individual
y tiene está en su último año ya esté a
cono y lo envían a la parroquia cuatro
días a la semana
[Música]
hasta los 20 años en una vida normal no
tenía el menor deseo de ser sacerdote
los seminaristas los sacerdotes no somos
extraterrestres
iba a misa todos los domingos quería
formar una familia tener un trabajo y de
hecho cuando llegue hacia ti para
estudiar ingeniería
empecé a ir a capellanía de los
estudiantes de capellanía católica
en el curso de un fin de semana quedé
realmente conmovido por la gracia y el
amor de dios' y de manera inexplicable
en todo caso para la razón humana sentí
el deseo de ser sacerdote
esta revelación mística asignó su
compromiso inmediato con el celibato
era natural era evidente que no voy a
compartir mentar mi corazón o dividirlo
en dos
no podía tener un amor de preferencia
por una joven
y luego por otro lado
querer consagrarme por tanto a dios y al
pueblo de dios
[Música]
etienne se ha estado preparando durante
nueve años para abandonar su sexualidad
cualquier vida de pareja y sus deseos de
paternidad
el seminario es una verdadera escuela de
libertad somos libres de decir lo que
queramos con nuestro acompañante
espiritual él está obligado a mantener
el secreto absoluto así que no le dirá
nada a nadie
[Música]
réplica de la capilla real de versalles
la edificación es considerada un
monumento histórico
para los seminaristas los tiempos de
oración ocupan un lugar central y marcan
el ritmo de sus vidas
[Música]
aquí en el seminario le enseñamos a los
candidatos sobre esa dimensión del
celibato consagrado hablamos con ellos
acerca de eso y también lo hacemos en
conversaciones más individuales para
asegurarnos de que realmente se trata de
una decisión pensada y no sólo una
decisión impulsiva haber tenido una
experiencia espiritual muy fuerte no
necesariamente significa que se servirá
al señor como un célibe consagrado
desde el 2000 los seminaristas deben
asistir a un módulo dedicado a las
diversas adicciones
videojuegos alcohol y pornografía
tenemos sesiones con psicólogos también
con un sexólogo que también ayuda en
este tema de la sexualidad a entender
mejor cómo funciona esa sexualidad qué
sentido tiene que es bella que el señor
se la dio a los hombres ya las mujeres
así que esta decisión del celibato se
construye con todos estos elementos
y desde 2016 la iglesia católica de
francia promueve en todos los seminarios
del país sesiones regulares sobre la
prevención de la pedofilia
es tarea de los formadores discernir las
fragilidades en aptitudes y rechazar las
candidaturas riesgosas en el seno de
estas comunidades exclusivamente
masculinas
y vivir según de justicia damos gracias
por tantas bendiciones de jesucristo
nuestro señor amén
en unas semanas etienne se irá de este
lugar de aprendizaje será ordenado
sacerdote para la diócesis de puntual en
el noroeste de país
personalmente estoy totalmente a favor
de este celibato porque en una sociedad
que ha rechazado con mucha frecuencia la
pregunta por dios el hecho de que los
hombres pero también la religiosa se
hayan tomado votos de serie button iba
y hayan abandonado todo por dios es un
signo importante fuerte eso también da
deseos de entregarse por completo de
dejarlo todo por dios
el tiempo de dar marcha atrás hasta el
mismo día de su ordenación
la pregunta para mí es pensar cómo voy a
mantenerme fiel a la palabra que di a
esta consagración de por vida
mientras que sepa que existe esta
relación viva entre dios y yo a través
de la oración si hay dudas esas dudas
podrán disiparse con facilidad a partir
del momento en el que se recuerda esa
relación que se tiene con jesucristo en
la relación viva
a veces puede haber preguntas si pueden
surgir ciertos sentimientos entre
comillas amorosos pero es en esos
momentos donde se vuelve a tomar por
físico
a pesar de que han aumentado los
candidatos que provienen del extranjero
cada año hay menos voluntarios para el
celibato consagrado en francia raúl
nació y creció en camerún llegó a la
región parisina hace 20 años y entró a
este seminario siete años después
para mí
y
me bautizaron a los 14 años así que yo
hice el procedimiento para abrir el
bautizo
vivía igual que todo el mundo
tuve novias no muchas pero si tú alguno
hubiese medio sacerdote en casarme tal
vez habría ido a otra iglesia
algo
en el año previo a la entrada en el
seminario se suele hacer un retiro con
los jesuitas
fueron 30 días de silencio y oración
y cada día nos reuníamos con un director
espiritual
y un día estaba en cuartos estaba en la
cama con su móvil
llorando a lágrima viva
porque me estaba dando cuenta y volvía a
sentir que dios siempre había estado
presente en mi vida y que me amaba con
una buena venta
pronto serás sacerdote en la isla de
francia su opinión sobre la
sacralización de los sacerdotes célibes
es clara
hemos oído acerca de los escándalos eran
sacerdotes célibes no es que por ser
célibe yo era mejor son hombres como
todo el mundo no había que sacralizar
en cuanto a la homosexualidad de los
seminarios en la iglesia raúl dice nunca
haberla visto
la dirección que se encarga de formar
los sacerdotes y clamó
dice claramente que toda persona con una
tendencia homosexual
no puede ser admitida la formación
sacerdotal
la iglesia no condena a los homosexuales
es homosexual
el papá francisco decía quién soy yo
para condenar pero condena la práctica
no creo que la iglesia siempre función
para personas homosexuales
buscamos es que los candidatos sean
personas apacibles y equilibradas y que
asuman plenamente ese ministerio
sacerdotal
[Música]
en este lugar donde se forman los
futuros hombres de iglesia el discurso
oficial no puede diferir del que
proviene del vaticano
la homosexualidad es un pecado para la
iglesia católica pero en la página web
de la santa sede- aparece la siguiente
consigna
[Música]
en caso de tendencias homosexuales que
sólo serían la expresión de un problema
transitorio como por ejemplo una
adolescencia aún no concluida éstas
deben ser claramente superadas al menos
tres años antes de la ordenación
diaconal
ahora la cantera de selección del
sacerdocio es bastante estrecha son
hombres que a fin de cuentas han estado
inmersos desde su más temprana edad en
el catolicismo y que a menudo han
asistido a una escuela privada que han
sido monaguillos scouts es decir que han
vivido en medios muy practicantes y que
se han vuelto también muy muy muy
minoritarios
en este tipo de familias muy
conservadoras sexualidad dividida
abiertamente en la sociedad y
eventualmente con una pareja no es un
mundo de posibilidades para un joven que
no se siente atraído por el matrimonio
heterosexual así que se encamina hacia
el sacerdocio última gala
amor por la iglesia católica o por una
persona la mayoría de los sacerdotes
sexualmente activos han decidido no
escoger así que ejercen su ministerio y
en secreto tienen relaciones
clandestinas
algunas son efímeras pero a menudo
suelen ser duraderas muchas parejas son
homosexuales
nunca compartir con mi familia esta
homosexualidad espere 30 años para poder
hablar sobre mi identidad sexual
primero lo hablé con mi obispo que fue
muy comprensivo
incluso me sugirió retirarme a un
monasterio durante un año y me recomendó
ir a ver a un sacerdote encargado de
acompañar personas homosexuales
mi único deseo era poder unificar mi fe
y mi profunda identidad
su acompañante espiritual en el
seminario no tuvo la misma reacción
cuando se lo dije se cerró por completo
total
y fue cuando me pareció que su actitud
había sido
de niño didier no era consciente de su
diferencia sin embargo estaba seguro de
querer ser sacerdote
lo viví en mi story
mi padre era violento con mi madre y esa
injusticia fue como una especie de
llamado para obrar y jesucristo
hay un rey por la justicialista
la otra razón de su vocación es que
'francia despenalizó la homosexualidad
solo hasta 1982
fue durante los años quiero vivir o 20
que tarde o temprano dios me daría la
fuerza para curarme de eso sí estaba
pecado
por la gracia de la ordenación lograría
superar eso que estaba en mí que no era
el sacerdocio me parecía la única
porque una plaza
a sus 20 años decidió entrar en el
seminario
me sentía más cercano algunos parecía
que teníamos la misma identidad sexual
pero eso era un tabú cada uno lo vivía
interiormente es acá
esa época del seminario era un lugar
para confiar y no sabía que podía hablar
al respecto y luego sentirse mejor es
trabajar en ella
[Música]
cuando recaía en esa atracción o en la
menstruación
lo sentía como un fracaso frente a este
compromiso para el que me estaba
preparando
sacerdote y enamorado a la vez seguía
viviendo cada día con esa atención
constante
[Música]
ahora me reúno con los excluidos a
través de mi ministerio
[Música]
y le dije
y descubrí que si me siento cercano a
esos excluidos es porque yo también me
siento así
[Música]
a través de su testimonio didier y sami
esperan ayudar a que la iglesia y la
sociedad evolucionen
a mí no me molesta que sea sacerdote es
su vida si él escogió hacer eso yo lo
acepto tal como es
no soy solo un sacerdote más
el ser sacerdote es una función pero que
todo soy un hombre tengo mi vida de
pareja tengo amigos vivo lo mismo que
todo el mundo me ve
cuando hay que celebrar una boda de lo
que significa experimentar el amor entre
dos personas
conozco las dificultades conozco las
ventajas y los esfuerzos que se deben
hacer para mantener una relación
vengo de una comunidad musulmana
entonces está prohibido también es un
pecado tengo amigos que lo saben mi
familia por supuesto no tal vez lo sepan
algún día no se elige ser homosexual
simplemente es amor
el amor
[Música]
creo que es posible decir que hay un 50%
de sacerdotes homosexuales
practicantes
según el discurso facial normalmente los
candidatos homosexuales no pueden
volverse sacerdotes eso crea un doble
cabo para las personas que actualmente
son homosexuales y que eventualmente
también son practicantes en términos de
sexualidad
paradójicamente si se sigue
desarrollando un discurso homofóbico un
poco agresivo en la iglesia como se ha
visto qué ocurre desde los años 80 ante
el hecho de que las sociedades
normalicen progresivamente la
homosexualidad se atrae cada vez más a
personas homosexuales también ha
interiorizado por completo la homofobia
[Música]
aunque la mayoría de los sacerdotes
prefieren tener dobles vidas algunos han
colgado sus sotanas para vivir
plenamente sus historias de amor
[Música]
una decisión poco común y difícil que
patrice tomó hace 18 años
proveniente de una familia muy
practicante de ocho hijos sus padres
soñaban con que uno de ellos fuera
sacerdote ése sería patrice cuando
terminó el colegio entró al seminario y
se ordenó a los 27 años
[Música]
esta es la postración así acostado en el
suelo se reza por el candidato para
darle la fuerza la valentía de continuar
con su vocación la abnegación el don de
sí la humildad
esta es la imposición de las manos por
el obispo es el gesto de la transmisión
del don de dios en la iglesia para mí es
un gesto simbólico que me designa como
un actor importante de la iglesia es
sobre todo eso más que una especie de
poder mágico que me habría sido
transmitido aunque esa era exactamente
la pasión que tenían mis padres cuando
me volví sacerdote mis padres y mi madre
en particular pensaban que yo tenía
prácticamente las manos de ellos
sería sacerdote hasta sus 38 años hasta
cuando se enamoró de la futura madre de
sus hijos por ella y a escondidas lo
abandonó todo una noche su parroquia su
hogar sus fieles
el 23 de mayo de 2003 empacamos todo en
el pequeño camión que habíamos alquilado
con mi mobiliario mis cosas y a las 2 de
la mañana cuando terminamos fuimos a la
oficina de correos donde mande
doscientas cartas dirigidas a distintas
personas explicándoles mi decisión
un mes después le avisó a su obispo para
trace estaba a cargo de 25 pueblos en la
región de ver corts
aprecie mucho ese trabajo de
acompañamiento tanto los nacimientos
como las bodas y los duelos
pero entre las uniones y los bautizos su
sensación de soledad afectiva iba en
aumento
al final me sentía un poco ajeno a eso
estaba un poco al margen era como el
espectador y el acompañante pero varias
veces pensaba eso no es para flow tú
escribiste otra cosa ser sacerdote y de
cierta manera estaba excluyente
[Música]
había momentos de mucha soledad que
trataba de atravesar con la mayor
valentía posible y luego había muchos
otros momentos en los que me sentían muy
animados creo que eso me permitió
soportar porque siempre tenía algo que
hacer entonces me involucraba mucho en
todo lo que hacía porque creía en ello
me hacía falta el aspecto relacional
afectuoso físico esa especie de compañía
cotidiana de afecto de gestos de cariño
de intercambios particulares con una
persona esas cosas a las que llamamos
amor a fin de cuentas
[Música]
por más que se diga que dios es amor que
se da la vida por amor para mí
claramente no era suficiente había una
característica del amor que yo no
lograba experimentar que era la
expresión de mí mismo de todo mi ser
incluyendo el plano afectivo y sexual
que no existía y yo sufría para eso 16
[Música]
patrice se casó con la mujer con la que
se fugó tuvieron tres hijas y luego se
divorciaron
desde hace nueve años vive con sylvie su
nueva pareja no se arrepiente para nada
de su nuevo camino salvo de la reacción
de algunos familiares
y el precio que pague tal vez fue la
incomprensión de algunos miembros de mi
familia no solo les parecía insensato
sino que además lo consideraban una
traición mientras que para mí era un
logro personal y un logro de mi proyecto
estábamos totalmente en desacuerdo así
que tuve que mantenerme alejado de
personas muy cercanas de mi familia para
no sufrir por eso
actualmente patrice tiene un trabajo
administro un centro de ayuda médico
social
es cierto que en la tradición católica
se es sacerdote de por vida en como la
crisis' mini sea incluso cuando se
abandona el ministerio se sigue siendo
el sacerdote
así que yo seguía teniendo la impresión
de que para los demás yo estaba con un
sacerdote y de que era culpable sentía
un poco de vergüenza frente a los
valores que me enseñaron que me
transmitieron mis padres y mi familia
ahora estoy en una búsqueda intelectual
filosófica ni siquiera sé qué significa
medida sexista no lo sé y a fin de
cuentas importa poco creo que lo mejor
que podemos hacer es vivir como hermanos
los unos con los otros amén
mariah él es una oyente voluntaria de la
asociación prendió una plataforma de
apoyo abierta para sacerdotes religiosas
y obispos que llevan una doble vida pero
las que llaman casi siempre son las
parejas de hombres religiosos las
llamadas son anónimas hoy mariel recibe
una deste madagascar
virtuales de 20 años es la pareja de un
sacerdote
si
la situación sigue siendo la misma con
su pareja o la mamá
la mayor parte del tiempo nos vemos una
o dos veces a la semana vamos a lugares
públicos siempre me recuerda que puedo
escoger que puedo cambiar de vida que él
no me está obligando
víctor sabe que no es la primera mujer
de este eclesiástico
que yo sepa soy la segunda o incluso la
tercera
trate de acabar con esta historia pero
no pude
[Música]
él no me ha hecho nada malo
a nivel social en la familia es un poco
difícil pero entre nosotros es
maravilloso
esta relación ha llevado a virtual a
abordar varias veces lejos de su hogar
sola
[Música]
sabía que sería difícil entonces tome la
decisión en contra de mi voluntad
mariel también es pareja de un sacerdote
viven juntos desde hace 20 años
se mantiene en el anonimato para que él
no tenga que abandonar su iglesia
[Música]
nos conocimos por fuera de la iglesia
por unos amigos en común
yo no sabía que él era sacerdote fue
durante un fin de semana
cuando descubrió que era sacerdote ya me
había enamorado de él y fue difícil dar
marcha atrás
al igual que la mayoría de los
sacerdotes con una doble vida él no
quiere abandonar su ministerio
en esa época no me imaginaba que sería
tan difícil y todas las privaciones
frustraciones y dolores que conlleva
no podemos compartir una cena familiar
juntos podemos irnos de vacaciones pero
siempre debemos ser discretos siempre
debemos mentir y al mismo tiempo hay
momentos muy hermosos pero solo cuando
estamos los dos cuando él no tiene nada
programado en su agente soy la quinta
rueda de las carrozas
[Música]
se separaron durante cinco años y luego
retomaron su romance
y los demás me ven como una serie eterna
que no tiene a nadie en su vida por lo
menos ya conoció a mis hijos los ha
visto una o dos veces lo presento
siempre como un amigo mis hijos no
sospechan nada no es fácil me gustaría
poder compartirlo con sus hijos por su
lado nadie lo sabe ninguno de sus
familiares o amigos realmente me hace
pensar que soy solo su amante
[Música]
según la asociación prensa en francia
hay cientos de mujeres que viven con
sacerdotes amantes clandestinas a su
pesar por pecado de amor
siento rabia porque realmente es el
hombre que me corresponde existe el
matrimonio para todo el mundo existe el
divorcio la sociedad ha evolucionado que
cambiaría si los religiosos y religiosas
tienen a alguien en su vida a la iglesia
que es tan santa no le importa el
sufrimiento que vivimos
es demasiado fases los obispos tienen
todo el poder y la iglesia también
nosotros sólo queremos vivir como lo
hace todo el mundo
de contulmo
[Música]
arzobispo de burgos monseñor wood está a
cargo de la formación y la vida de los
sacerdotes en la conferencia de
sacerdotes de francia el organismo que
reúne a todos los cardenales y
sacerdotes del país
creo que eso los lleva a tener una doble
vida
capital es capital que no sean
sacerdotes o que renuncien a hacerlo
creo que los bautizados no quieren tener
un sacerdote hipócrita pienso que es
mejor no ejercer una misión así para el
pueblo de dios
lo que a mí me sorprende porque no es
honesto con esas mujeres y creo que no
está bien
y además tampoco es honesto con su
comunidad
no sé cómo pueden mirarlos a los ojos
y dónde
hija única cristian creció en un hogar
problemático su madre era una católica
muy practicante de la que le gustaba
mucho salir su padre un hombre agnóstico
casero y autoritario
había un ambiente de mucha violencia él
rompía cosas pero eran sobre todo
violencias verbales aunque no muy graves
de niña a la pequeña cristian soñaba con
curar a las personas y tener una familia
grande
pensaba que me gustaría tener mi propia
familia y que fuera una familia próspera
y feliz con niños que no tuviera ese
ambiente que yo conocí en mi infancia
[Música]
a los 22 años empezó a estudiar medicina
y conoció a un hombre él estaba
impaciente por casarse con ella y tener
hijos christian o dudó y decidió a
confesárselo a su amigo sacerdote
cuando empecé a contarle él me escuchaba
pero como amigo
todavía no le había dado una respuesta
al hombre que quería casarse conmigo y
fue en ese momento cuando él me dijo
pero yo te amo
me di cuenta de que yo también lo amaba
fue completamente instantáneo
iniciaron entonces 45 años de vida
clandestina
45 años de felicidad pero en la sombra y
en el secreto al igual que todas las
parejas de sacerdotes está médica
interior hizo las reglas de prudencia
todas las parejas clandestinas de
sacerdotes lo hace para irse lejos
porque es una liberación
yo esperaba poder vivir una vida normal
durante tres semanas
tomarse de la mano poder darse un beso
en público delante de todo el mundo
una vez alcanzada la edad de jubilación
sacerdotal la pareja esperaba poder
tener una vida normal a los 75 años
pero él murió a ese año nunca tuvieron
hijos muy rápido al comienzo me dijo si
no fuera sacerdote tendríamos nuestros
hijos sufría mucho por eso
[Música]
pero no queríamos que nuestros hijos
vivieran con el peso de esa
clandestinidad
sí sí no
[Música]
es hija de un sacerdote
a los 43 años todavía vive una vida
anónima es su manera de protegerse
[Música]
tengo aquí a una iglesia porque es
tranquilo me gusta ver los vitrales por
curiosidad estética pero la religión me
da igual no tengo fe es un lugar que
asocio con el sitio en el que trabajaba
mi padre así que vengo porque es como si
él estuviera aquí como si viviera aquí
pero al mismo tiempo la religión le hizo
mucho daño sufrimos mucho con las
intimidaciones con los horrores y todo
eso me espanta
vive en una pequeña casa cerca del
océano atlántico un refugio donde
conserva los recuerdos de su padre un
huérfano acogido por los jesuitas
esta es la maleta donde está la mayoría
de las cosas que me quedan de él no
tengo muchos pero hay algunas
estas son fotos donde aparecen con la
sotana de los jesuitas debía tener 25 o
30 años y debían ser los años 60 estas
son las únicas fotos que tengo de él de
esa época realmente nunca quiso hablarme
de cuando había sido sacerdote porque
era demasiado doloroso para él los
jesuitas tienen la reputación de ser los
intelectuales de la iglesia porque su
formación dura 15 años ninguna mujer es
aceptada en su orden
[Música]
mis padres se conocieron en un colegio
en la región de lyon
mi padre era profesor de filosofía y
conoció a mi madre que era una joven
estudiante de letras
y dice enamorar
y padre decidió abandonar las órdenes
para casarse con ella
hablo con las autoridades pontificales
dos años después nacieron lea y después
su hermano
[Música]
padre tenía una familia grande tenía
cuatro hermanos así que había muchas
personas en la familia todos estos son
mis primos no sé quiénes son tengo sus
fotos pero no los conozco rechazaron a
mi padre cuando abandonó el sacerdocio y
se casó y tuvo hijos porque nosotros
somos los hijos de satán no debimos
haber nacido de repente
el amor
los padres de mi madre estaban furiosos
eran inmigrantes españoles así que para
ellos la religión era sagrada
cuando supieron que mi madre se había
enamorado de un religioso fue un drama
la echaron
rechazados por sus familias se fueron a
buscar trabajo al oeste de francia
el único puesto de trabajo que mi padre
encontró fue en bretaña en un pueblo muy
pequeño y las personas descubrieron que
tenía un pasado religioso había
encontrado un puesto como profesor de
filosofía en un colegio católico y se
volvió un infierno
empezaron a acusar nos nos enviaban
cartas con insultos paquetes con
adentro amenazas de muerte hacían
grafitis en las paredes y lo peor de
todo fue cuando iniciaron un incendio
las personas que nos acosaban eran los
padres de los alumnos de la escuela
católica es decir que todos eran
creyentes practicantes
pensaban que si un antiguo religioso les
daba clases de filosofía a sus hijos nos
iba a pervertir
[Música]
lea se unió a la asociación en fondos y
lounge hijos del silencio así fue cómo
pudo acceder a los archivos de su padre
me dijeron algo horrible me dijeron que
purgaban el archivo de las personas como
mi padre el vivió veinte años siendo
religioso y en 20 años no puede haber
sólo 5 páginas de archivo no soy tonta
si hay 5 páginas es porque efectivamente
se deshicieron del resto
[Música]
en el mundo habría decenas de miles de
niños de sacerdotes y religiosos la
iglesia los esconde desde hace siglos
pero desde 2017 cambió el discurso
oficial
todo sacerdote con un hijo debe
abandonar el sacerdocio
causando
tuve un caso en otra diócesis
él tenía una mujer que estaba esperando
un hijo y le dijo que no podía seguir
con su ministerio
y que debía ocuparse de la mujer y de su
hijo
y que el bien de su hijo era lo
primordial
desde 2019 y la iglesia de francia ha
organizado dos reuniones inéditas con
hijos de sacerdotes el objetivo es abrir
el diálogo y ayudarles con su situación
[Música]
si ya es presidenta de la asociación con
fondos y los hijos del silencio asistió
a esos encuentros
después de todo lo que pasó con las
historias de pedofilia y de sacerdotes
que abusaron de los niños los medios
hicieron un gran trabajo y se estableció
una comisión
a partir de ahí empezamos a trabajar con
ellos
esta es la carta dirigida a los obispos
y superiores mayores sobre la acogida y
acompañamiento a los hijos de sacerdotes
y religiosos
fomentando el acceso a los archivos de
las diócesis y congregaciones religiosas
después cada obispo es libre de actuar o
no según su propia conciencia es la
primera vez en la francia que nos
escuchan
es también la primera vez que la iglesia
católica de francia admite la existencia
de estos niños
durante años se le pedía a los
sacerdotes que se quedaran en sus
parroquias y en sus ministerios y que
abandonaran a sus mujeres y niños eso es
indigno de una iglesia católica
si bien también es hija de un sacerdote
lo descubrió a sus 44 años y solo hasta
este año al heredar un escritorio de su
madre se encontró con esta carta
es una carta escrita por mi padre que
descubrí después de la muerte de mi
madre se puede decir que es una carta de
amor
mi padre trataba de usted a mi madre en
ese momento incluso aparece mi nombre
esto es lo que dice es que al ver a esa
pequeña niña una niña rodeada por su
padre rodeada por su madre que sólo
tenía ojos para ella pensé que usted nos
imaginaria así y me vino a la mente una
reflexión que usted hizo me gustaría
tener una pequeña sylvian con ojos
negros y si usted tendrá esos ojos
negros y esa pequeña con rostro infantil
será nuestra hija si usted así lo quiere
es un hermoso regalo que me llegó del
más allá porque ahora mis dos padres ya
no están
[Música]
así de donde tomó tiempo reconstruir el
rompecabezas de su vida y la de su
familia
[Música]
bajo la educación judeocristiana que
recibí era casarse y tener hijos
eso es todo un sacerdote no se casa
ese es el esquema clásico en el que yo
crecí y viví toda mi vida durante 44
años
crecí con esos esquemas y un día mi
verdad se volvió diferente mejores
cereza mi verdad ahora es otra y sin
embargo existe
su esposo siempre la ha apoyado él
mantiene su fe pero confiesa ir con
menos frecuencia a la iglesia desde las
revelaciones de pedofilia
tokman tiene una rigidez que a veces es
necesaria para poder gobernar
pero por otro lado tiene el
inconveniente de que le toma mucho
tiempo cambiar el papá francisco se
esfuerza por cambiar algunas cosas y es
necesario que logre quitar algunas
trabas cambiar algunas costumbres deja a
otras las grandes instituciones les
resulta difícil cuestionarse
sigo siendo católica cristiana
practicante y aunque pude haberme ido
miles de veces de esta iglesia católica
me quedé porque los cambios se pueden
hacer desde adentro
[Música]
no se pueden hacer si uno se va tirando
la puerta y gritando esa es mi opinión
personal como cristiano
a la máxima posición personal
autogestión ética
el celibato no está prescrito en la
biblia los hombres casados podían
acceder al sacerdocio en el siglo 12 se
volvió obligatorio para evitar que los
bienes de la iglesia no fueran
acaparados de padre a hijo una regla que
todavía no se observa por completo
porque al menos ocho papas ocultaron
hijos ilegítimos
en su país de olga presidente del comité
de la falda que promueve el feminismo en
la iglesia católica en 2020 fue la
primera mujer en postularse para el
arzobispado de lyon para suceder al
cardenal bárbaro para ella no cabe duda
hay que abandonar el celibato de los
sacerdotes la jesús fue la primera razón
es la que todo el mundo conoce que los
sacerdotes sufren y medie un aumento de
abrir esa posibilidad para quienes lo
deseen
la segunda que me parece menos segura
que ocurra es que eso aumentaría la
cantidad de vocaciones sacerdotales
y la tercera es que la iglesia católica
no puede tener un discurso sensato sobre
la sexualidad es una sexual y si tuviera
sacerdotes casados tendría el derecho a
hablar de eso
[Música]
en 2021 no habrá cambios en la posición
a firmada por el papá
el celibato eclesiástico
es una posición que no cambiará en los
próximos años justamente porque no es
solamente una función disciplinar hasta
que resistimos
sino también algo místico religioso es
algo arraigado en el celibato
[Música]
es una institución
no sólo es humana como escuela como
sobre todo una institución que es una
emanación de dios
y entonces no puede reconocer que ha
sido demasiado magia idénticamente
por eso se podría decir que la
estrategia de la iglesia siempre es una
especie de eternización de sus
decisiones entonces
esta manera la disciplina del celibato
que está históricamente fechada y podría
deshacerse se complicarán con miles de
razones espirituales para que parezca
que provienen directamente de
un tema
la primera reforma profunda que se lleve
a cabo en la iglesia tendrá un efecto
dominó sobre otras reformas
es muy atemorizante para honesto ver que
de repente una sección de la estructura
se mueve y que la segunda antes era
también es opone a la estructura entera
en peligro es algo muy angustiante y no
es una decisión fácil de tomar región
hueso por eso creo que francisco no la
tomará los bosques
desde 2019 en francia ocurrió un hecho
inédito los obispos se pronunciaron
públicamente a favor de reestablecer el
matrimonio para sacerdotes
[Música]
después de haber celebrado la misa mark
se reúne con su familia y sus amigos
para un almuerzo dominical en la víspera
de la reunión con su obispo ya tomó su
decisión quiere abandonar la iglesia
espera tener una salida tranquila para
no escandalizar a sus fieles y pedir
personalmente la reducción al estado
laico
[Música]
lo que ha cambiado es poder vivir una
vida común y corriente de familia por lo
general cuando un sacerdote sale de la
misa un domingo a mediodía la mayor
parte del tiempo está solo en su
presbiterio en mi caso los domingos son
familiares muy normales los pasó con
amigos y creo que eso es lo que más ha
cambiado la vida
[Música]
al comienzo sus amigos se sorprendieron
y luego se alegraron por su historia
pero temen por su futuro
puede haber gente malintencionada porque
sé que no es fácil él tendrá que tomar
decisiones porque la iglesia no cambiará
en 5 minutos y ciertamente estamos aquí
cambiará
la situación es preocupante porque
pensamos que habrá obstáculos en su
camino y eso no es lo que uno quiere
para sus amigos
pero ver lo felices que están me da
tranquilidad es una vieja institución de
hace 2000 años tiene sus reglas pero eso
no es nada frente a una historia de amor
qué es esto
al día siguiente mark se dio cuenta de
que su jerarquía había tomado la
iniciativa
basándose en un podcast donde la pareja
daba testimonio de su situación
utilizando seudónimos su obispo lo
suspendió definitivamente de todas sus
funciones el instituto católico donde
daba clases finalizó su contrato ahora
marc está buscando trabajo y puso en
marcha procesos legales entretanto la
pareja tiene pensado casarse pronto en
la alcaldía
[Música]
recuerde que si les gustó este reportaje
puede verlo nuevamente a través de
nuestra página web france24 punto com me
despido de ustedes hasta una próxima
oportunidad
[Música]